okay um
good morning and welcome to this uh
licensing act subcommittee it's the 4th
of november at
10 am
the committee is called to
consider an application for a transfer
premises license in respect of the crown
in one crown street stone market
applicants and those making
representations have a right to be heard
at these
subcommittees under regulations 15 and
16 of the hearing regulation and
accordingly we'll be following
this procedure
once the formalities of the subcommittee
have been completed
the the full hearing will take place and
that will start with the council's
licensing officer
summarizing the report for the
subcommittee
mr leech's applicant will then be
invited to make his representations to
the subcommittee in support of his
application
followed by the the police's objector
who will then present their reasons as
to why the application should be
rejected
mr leach will then be able to sum up and
address any objections as he sees
fit and appropriate
and then
after each representation questions may
be asked these will be led by the chair
of the subcommittee
and just remind you that they will only
be questions as to the presentation it's
not an opportunity to um actually
contradict or or to argue with each
other this is a point where you just
make clarifications
um as i said the the chair will run
proceedings um so please follow those
instructions accordingly
um once everyone has made their
representations and as i said mr leach
will be the final person to make his
representations as the applicant
the subcommittee will then go into
private session to to make their
decision
um so i'll now hand over to the chair of
the subcommittee as councillor kathy
guthrie thank you
well good morning everybody good morning
mr leech mr mckester and everybody else
present here
welcome to the virtual meeting of the
licensing subcommittee
i'd like to remind everyone present at
this meeting that it will be broadcast
to youtube and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented
to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and the possible
use of those sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
the virtual meeting etiquette we do have
some
is please ensure the microphones are
muted when you're not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair so
please await your turn may we have
apologies for absence please
none receive chair
thank you
declarations of interest by councillors
there are none
so may i introduce everybody to you i'm
the chairman mrs councillor kathy
guthrie
uh we have councillor david muller could
you
yes good morning everybody
and counselor penny otton
you're on mute but i think um i think we
can see you are you yeah
uh we also have our legal advisor whom
we've heard first of all nigel lulu
the licensing officer k sanders if you'd
make yourself known please
good morning everybody
good morning thank you
licensing officer catherine green can
you make yourself known please
morning everyone
good morning thank you very much
licensing officer kerry chandler
good morning everybody
good morning
the assistant food manager food and
safety licensing joe wyatt
she's not here chair
oh is she not we haven't got her here
right
and the governance officer whom you've
heard karen would you like to make
yourself known as well please good
morning everyone
good morning
so good morning mr leech would you like
to just introduce yourself and advise if
you have any representations with you
good morning good morning oh good
morning thank you uh no it's just uh
myself i tried to get some help but um
through the uh headway charity for uh
brain injuries but um now they said only
the ghosts to magistrates they're
stepping
right but nonetheless that's very much
so it's yourself and
i think you'll be able to follow the
proceedings quite easily we hope uh yeah
no what it is i just struggle where i
had a like brain image i can just
struggle a little bit all right
on the phone so i can get like fits and
stuff so
i will take it easy and we'll see how it
goes
yeah no i should be all right i've got
my headphones on because i can't
yeah it's just a bit funny i can't
explain it yeah yeah all right then if
you'd like to mute yourself for the
moment
so we've got um all of us got the
receipt of the procedure and mr leach i
think you understand what's going on too
is that correct nod your head i'll get
you on that one
yeah good
right
so can we have uh the responsible
authority uh to introduce yourself
please um and your
stated position i believe that's mr
mckessler
good morning my name is malcolm mckesser
i'm the licensing officer with suffolk
police licensing unit
and i'm here on behalf of the chief
constable
thank you very much
now um i'm speaking to both of you mr
leach and mr kessler would either party
like to withdraw the either the
application or the representation mr
leech first do you wish to withdraw the
application
thank you very much
so my next question is to the licensing
officer
have there been any requests from the
parties for permission to call witnesses
no chair
thank you and have the parties indicated
they wish to present documentary or
other material
yes chair
and nigel i think you might have some
indication there yes
mr lee did submit a couple of emails
which he sent to the licensing officer
i've had a look at them they do not
relate to the the application um and
that they refer to other matters so i
don't believe they should be brought
before the subcommittee although mr
malik may refer to them at some point
thank you
so you understand that mr leech um it's
got to be relevant to this specific
thing
right now mr leech um a very difficult
one this
but we need to be succinct and listen to
what you've got to say so how long do
you think you need to present the case
as to why you
need a license not history of why we're
here today
no that's fair enough but the only
reason this is happening is because i
was targeted by the suffolk police and
uh but that's not
that we we can't discuss at the moment
it's
why
ha what you should be telling us why you
want a license so how long do you think
that might take a license so how long do
you think that might take um no that's
not going to take long but like i said
councillor um we wouldn't be here um
unless i wasn't assaulted by the police
and now i deal with the essex police
because um the uh suffolk contemporary
didn't act when i was assaulted harassed
um i was assaulted by wpc
and they laughed about it
we need to keep focus on on your
application for this license you need to
present to the subcommittee
why you should be why you should be
granted a license
um so
how much time do you think you need to
make that presentation
well i don't know cancer i mean i've got
a personal alcohol license um
i'm not a convicted
criminal
okay okay
involved with criminality i don't know
what else to say we're going to come to
these points in a minute at the moment
we're going through
um sort of the administrative part of
this meeting in that we want to sort of
find out how long you're going to need
to make your presentation would you say
15 minutes would be appropriate
would you say 15 minutes would be
appropriate um yeah yeah probably yeah
thank you that's really helpful mr leech
because we want to focus on why you want
this license
so that's excellent so 15 minutes and um
obviously questions will come out so
we'll hear all sorts of things
and so to the police now um so mr leech
if you can switch yours off for the
moment please
oh yeah no problem thank you so mr
mckessler how long do you think you
would need
i believe 15 minutes should do
lovely thank you very much
um because the same time for all is fair
um
so we now get to the point um where we
exclude the public because this is a
private matter mr leech and so that you
understand this will not be for public
consumption
so you understand that
so i must put forward the following
motion
on the basis that the subcommittee
considers that the public interest in
excluding the public outweighs the
public interest in its deliberation
being held in public
it is resolved that under section 100a
brackets 4 of the local government act
1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for item 6 on the grounds that it
involves the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in part one
of schedule 12 of the act
on the grand set out in regulation 14
brackets ii
of the licensing act 2003 brackets
hearings brackets regulations
2005.
may i have a proposal to that motion
please
happy to propose chair
thank you councillor muller and a
seconder if i may i'll second that
chairman
thank you counselor